[Music]
Ayoo II did you know that the r-tx 2080
super was launching today yeah I was
just finalizing on the performance
charts where'd you think man
well uh would this help you change your
mind dude give them a positive review
okay I mean you've got all this money
just do your thing go buy a house buy
Lambo enjoy your life okay Oh
[Laughter]
back to reality folks so a new r-tx
super graphics card is here but it's a
bit of an odd one actually let's at the
stage first because they've been some
pretty big changes in last month
basically Nvidia new AMD was releasing
their Nabi cards and dropped the RT X xx
semi super and the RT X 2060 super right
before lunch it didn't help them all
that much because team red ended up with
some sweet GPUs at amazing prices you
can check out our review of those GPUs
right over here and so that brings us to
this the RT X 2080 super remember the RT
X 2070 super ended up almost matching
the older and more expensive
RTX 2080 well it really needed something
for folks who wanted to pay more for
better performance and so that's that's
that's what we're here with a new super
card but you know what
I don't think NVIDIA did enough to set
this card apart from their own lineup or
what AMD is currently offering so let's
get into what that means right after
quick message from our sponsor and by
the way timestamps will be linked in the
description down below or pinned in the
comments section looking for a solid
board to pair your 9 June CPU the azrog
Z 390 Taichi gets it right with robust
vrm designs for extreme overclocking a
12 phase power design for smooth power
delivery dual band Wi-Fi
three m dot two slots and reinforced PCI
connectors learn more about it down
below
okay so let's quickly recap what the our
TX 2080 super is all about before
heading right into overall performance
well it's basically an RT X 2080
replacement with more cores faster bass
and boost clocks and faster GTD r6
memory but if you look closely the specs
aren't all that much different it will
start at $700 for the founders edition
of course and go upwards from there
power consumption is quite a bit more -
and just remember the FE card isn't
Priora clock this time so Nvidia will be
counting on their board partners for
that so this is what Nvidia is r-tx line
up looks like right now with the
Arctic's 20 ATT is still sitting at a
thousand bucks or more and below that
the article is super for three hundred
dollars less then that's followed by the
Arctic's 2070 super and finally the RT X
2060 series it's pretty straightforward
stuff now as for the design it basically
looks like any other r-tx Super Series
the founders editions of course so you
get the downdraft coolers just like the
RT X 2070 super backplate eight plus six
pin power connector layout and that's
pretty much it
now I actually preferred this kind of a
design except for the stupid mirror
finish I don't exactly know what Nvidia
was thinking in the first place it just
ruins the aesthetics of this graphics
card I mean look at this I've just
fingerprints all over the place now
there have been some mixed reactions in
terms of what people think about the
5,700 X DS reference design but it'll be
interesting to see what board partners
do with the RX 5700 series I'm actually
really interested to check out the has
rock rx 5700 XD challenger it looks
pretty nice if you ask me there's also
another issue I want to bring up because
right now it's affecting how I look at
everyone up in videos new GPUs and it
isn't good guys unless you buy one
directly from Nvidia they're almost
impossible to find and most of them are
just ridiculously overpriced sure there
might be one or two at the starting at
price but with the rx 5700 XD and the rx
5700 around there's just no way I'd even
think of paying this so with this in
your mind taken
$700 price for the r-tx 2080 super with
a truck load of salt
I mean sure board partners are obligated
to come up with reference price versions
but that doesn't mean that they'll be
regularly available I mean there's no
business sense in producing a lower
priced version of a GPU if it can sell
the exact same one for more right let me
just take a breath before heading into
the performance segment so these are the
system specs were used with a ninety
nine hundred X that's overclocked far
enough to make sure that CPU
bottlenecking doesn't affect our results
too much before getting into individual
game benchmark let's take a look at the
overall performance from all the titles
we ended up testing so as you can see
Nvidia's changes really didn't do all
that much since
on average the r-tx twenty eighty super
only gets around eight percent better
performance than the standard RT x
twenty eighty and remember this is an
average across all games so some results
were higher than eight percent but a lot
of them were much less - to make matters
worse it's only about twelve percent
faster than an RT X 2070 super and that
card costs $200 less so guess what that
means yep the newest super has an
absolutely terrible overall value even
with the EVGA r-tx 2080s sitting at six
hundred thirty dollars right now not
only that but I'm sure some board
partner versions will be going for
almost eight hundred dollars and just
think about that for a sec you could buy
two rx 5700 XT cards for that price I
mean come on
but I also want you to take a look at
the RT X 28 ETI first of all it's almost
impossible to find one for $1000 and
most go for 11 in dollars or more the
gigabyte card we used has an average
price of 1150 with some shops selling it
for around $1,250
so as we start with the actual benchmark
charts let's have a chat you see after
seeing the performance gains and video
baked into other Super Series cards the
RT X 2080 version should have been so
much more so what happened well it's not
about giving you guys more value I think
Nvidia is desperately protecting the RT
X 2080 TI's thousand dollar price tag
you see when you add too much
performance to the RT X 2080 Super by
basing it off of the t 102 core
or introduce it at a more reasonable
price and boom VRTX 28 ET i can't be
sold for a grand anymore
it just feels like they didn't had
enough here to justify these 700 other
price and I think we all know bought
partners will charge even more for
pointless pre overclocked cards as well
I mean sure in some games performance
looks pretty decent but not for this
kind of cash most of the time the
Arctic's 20 of these super looked like a
bad choice but at other times it's just
a ripoff I also want to bring up the
good points some of you made in the arts
5,700 XD video lower-priced cards keep
getting faster and that's bad news for
the 20 hey super for example the arcs
5700 XD is an amazing value and even
though it's slower than the r-tx 2080
super it costs 300 bucks less that's a
huge amount of money that can be spent
on other upgrades and you won't be
missing all that much in terms of
performance even the Arctic's 2070 super
is within just 12% but you'd save a ton
of money by buying this one instead of
the 2080 super provided you can actually
find one for 500 dollars so there you
guys have it and I'm gonna end this
video by saying that the r-tx 2080 super
is just way too expensive for what it
offers there are plenty of lower priced
GPUs that you can buy and those won't
even cost a significant hit in terms of
performance my best advice is look
somewhere else and don't even bother
with the Arctic's 2080 super